[Music]
come on i want you to do what i want you
to do
a dark knight the caped crusader old
boogaloo bats there's a batman for all
seasons but whatever you call him he is
known far and wide as a comic book hero
who's managed to keep relevant in
entertainment for decades reinvented
time and time again to answer a nation's
distress bat signal call it was camp
colors and biff bang pao for the 1960s
the 80s found a taste for blockbuster
art deco madness and the 90s got the
best of it and the worst of it
[Music]
can i persuade you to take a sandwich
with you sir
i'll get drive through the world of the
2000s demanded realism and it got
christopher nolan's the dark knight
trilogy these days bruce is playing nice
with the justice league while awaiting
transformation as robert pattinson slips
on the cow for 2022's the batman holy
review aggregates because we have
gathered all the theatrical batman
movies in one list ranked by tomato
meter
[Music]
number 10 justice league fueled by his
restored faith in humanity and inspired
by superman's selfless act bruce wayne
enlists newfound ally diana prince to
face an even greater threat together
batman and wonder woman work quickly to
recruit a team to stand against a newly
awakened enemy despite the formation of
an unprecedented league of heroes batman
wonder woman aquaman cyborg and the
flash it may be too late to save the
planet from an assault of catastrophic
proportions starring ben affleck henry
cavill gal gadot and directed by zack
snyder critics say justice league leaps
over a number of dc movies but its
single bound isn't enough to shed the
murky aesthetic thin characters and
chaotic action that continue to dog the
franchise
um
[Music]
this isn't the plan no master wayne
this is the team
number nine batman having witnessed his
parents as brutal murderer as a child
millionaire philanthropist bruce wayne
fights crime in gotham city disguised as
batman a costumed hero who strikes fear
into the hearts of villains but when a
deformed madman who calls himself the
joker seizes control of gotham's
criminal underworld batman must face his
most ruthless nemesis ever while
protecting both his identity and his
love interest reporter vicki vale
starring michael keaton jack nicholson
kim bae singer and directed by tim
burton critics say an eerie haunting
spectacle batman succeeds as dark
entertainment even if jack nicholson's
joker too often overshadows the title
character
you killed my parents
what
huh
what are you talking about
i made you
you made me first
hey batman i mean i was a kid when i
killed your parents i mean i said i made
you you got to say you made me and
how childish you can get
you wouldn't hit a guy with glasses on
would you
[Music]
[Laughter]
what are you laughing at
number eight zack snyder's justice
league
in zack snyder's justice league
determined to ensure superman's ultimate
sacrifice was not in vain bruce wayne
aligns forces with diana prince with
plans to recruit a team of meta-humans
to protect the world from an approaching
threat of catastrophic proportions the
task proves more difficult than bruce
imagined as each of the recruits must
face the demons of their own past to
transcend that which held them back
allowing them to come together finally
forming an unprecedented league of
heroes now united batman wonder woman
aquaman cyborg and the flash may be too
late to save the planet from steppenwolf
to sod and darkseid and their dreadful
intentions starring ben affleck gal
gadot henry cavill and directed by zack
snyder critics say zack snyder's justice
league lives up to its title with a
sprawling cut that expands to fit the
director's vision and should satisfy the
fans who willed it into existence
[Music]
the energy is dissipating my golf it
worked
celebrate later off and i need the
nightcrawler thought you'd never ask
calls on the way initiating remote mode
[Music]
thank you alfred
don't mention it
number seven batman the movie cup howie
holy feature film batman won based on
the tongue-in-cheek camping 1960s
television series watch batman and robin
battle sharks catwoman the joker and the
riddler on the big screen can they try
to prevent the bad guys from taking over
the world with a wham and a pow and a
zip our heroes just might win starring
adam west burt ward caesar romero and
directed by leslie h martinson critics
say batman the movie elevates camp to an
art form and has a blast doing it every
gloriously tongue-in-cheek inch of the
way
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a b and c taking green water sir ah hey
anyone you know i can't take water
you want to live forever
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
click the back charges they've had about
enough i imagine
number six batman returns
the monstrous penguin who lives in the
sewers beneath gotham joins up with
wicked shock-headed businessman max
shrek to topple the batman once and for
all but when shrek's timid assistant
selena kyle finds out and shrek tries to
kill her she is transformed into the
sexy catwoman she teams up with the
penguin and shrek to destroy batman but
sparks fly unexpectedly when she
confronts the caved crusader starring
michael keaton danny devito michelle
pfeiffer and directed by tim burton
critics say director tim burton's dark
brooding atmosphere michael keaton's
work as a tormented hero and the
flawless casting of danny devito as the
penguin and christopher walken as well
christopher walken make batman returns
better than the first
[Music]
admiring your handiwork
touring the riot scene
gravely assessing the devastation
upstanding mayor's stuff
[Music]
you're not the mayor
things change
what do you want
ah
the direct approach
i admire that in a man with a mask
you don't really think you'll win do you
things change
meow
number five batman mask of the phantasm
in this extension of batman the animated
series the inner life of bruce wayne is
exposed as we uncover his dark past a
life-changing romance his first year as
a vigilante and the arrival of a
vengeful new villain starring kevin
conroy stacy keach dana delany and
directed by eric rodomski critics say
stylishly and admirably respectable of
the source material batman mask of the
phantasm succeeds where many of the
live-action batman adaptations have
failed
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
come on
[Music]
you're too late batman there are 20
miles of tunnels under this place and
they're all filled with high explosives
in five minutes everything goes up
number four batman begins
a young bruce wayne travels to the far
east where he's trained in the martial
arts by henry ducard a member of the
mysterious league of shadows when
descartes reveals the league's true
purpose the complete destruction of
gotham city wayne returns to gotham
intent on cleaning up the city without
resorting to murder with the help of
alfred his loyal butler and lucius fox a
tech expert at wayne enterprises batman
is born starring christian bale michael
kane liam neeson and directed by
christopher nolan critics say brooding
and dark but also exciting and smart
batman begins as a film that understands
the essence of one of the definitive
superheroes
he's flying on rooftops
uh
[Music]
oh
number three the dark knight rises
it has been eight years since batman in
collusion with commissioner gordon
vanished into the night assuming
responsibility for the death of harvey
den batman sacrificed everything for
what he and gordon hoped would be the
greater good however the arrival of a
cunning cat burglar and a merciless
terrorist named bane forced batman out
of exile and into a battle he may not be
able to win starring christian bale anne
hathaway tom hardy and directed by
christopher nolan critics say the dark
knight rises is an ambitious thoughtful
and potent action film that concludes
christopher nolan's franchise in
spectacular fashion
we lost him
how could you lose him
he's got a lot of firepower
what did you do
close it off gentlemen
like a rat in a trap gentlemen
you might have the wrong animal there
sir
number two the lego batman movie
there are big changes brewing in gotham
but if batman wants to save the city
from the joker's hostile takeover he may
have to drop the lone vigilante thing
try to work with others and maybe just
maybe learn to lighten up maybe his
superhero sidekick robin and loyal
butler alfred can show him a thing or
two starring will arnett michael sarah
rosario dawson and directed by chris
mckay critics say the lego batman movie
continues its blockbuster franchise's
winning streak with another round of
dizzyingly funny and beautifully
animated family-friendly mayhem
[Music]
what
it's the bad cave
oh my god oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my
gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh oh
my god oh my gosh oh my my gosh
batman whoa you're darn right whoa wait
does batman live in bruce wayne's
basement no bruce wayne lives in
batman's attic we can have sleepovers
every night no we can't whoa look it's
the bathtub wait don't touch that and
over there it's the bad space shuttle
please keep your hands up get the bat
zapped blind don't touch that either
no it's the bad kayak it's the bat doom
buggy gets the bat
shock repellent
uh
actually you can you can't touch that
it's completely useless whoa thanks
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
batman the killing joke
batman must save commissioner gordon
from the joker's twisted quest to drive
him insane starring kevin conroy mark
hamill ray wise and directed by sam liu
critics say batman the killing jokes
stilted retelling of the joker's origin
adds little to its iconic source
material further diminished by some
questionable story additions that will
have fans demanding justice for barbara
gordon so red hood
we meet again
stay away from me don't come any closer
monster
[Music]
come on
i'm itching all over
what's that
[Laughter]
uh
[Laughter]
batman forever
batman faces off against two foes the
schizophrenic horribly scarred former
district attorney harvey dent aka
two-face and the riddler a disgruntled
x-wing enterprises inventor seeking
revenge against his former employer by
unleashing his brain-sucking weapon on
gotham city's residence as the caped
crusader also deals with tortured
memories of his parents murder he has a
new romance with psychologist chase
meridian starring val kilmer tommy lee
jones jim carrey and directed by joel
schumacher critics say loud excessively
busy and often boring batman forever
nonetheless has the charisma of jim
carrey and tommy lee jones to offer mild
relief
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
somebody tell the fat lady she's on in
five
[Music]
[Music]
batman v superman dawn of justice
it's been nearly two years since
superman's colossal battle with zod
devastated the city of metropolis the
loss of life and collateral damage left
many feeling angry and helpless
including crime-fighting billionaire
bruce wayne convinced that superman is
now a threat to humanity batman embarks
on a personal vendetta to end his reign
on earth while the conniving lex luthor
launches his own crusade against the man
of steel starring ben affleck henry
cavill amy adams and directed by zach
snyder critics say batman v superman
dawn of justice smothers a potentially
powerful story and some of america's
most iconic superheroes in a grim
whirlwind of effects driven action
here i am
bruce
please
i was wrong you have to listen to me
lex wants us
you don't
understand there's no time
i understand
and finally number one the dark knight
with the help of allies lieutenant jim
gordon and d.a harvey dent batman has
been able to keep a tight lid on crime
in gotham city but when a vile young
criminal calling himself the joker
suddenly throws a town into chaos the
caped crusader begins to try to fine
line between heroism and vigilantism
starring christian bale heath ledger
aaron eckhart and directed by
christopher nolan critics say dark
complex and unforgettable the dark
knight succeeds not just as entertaining
comic book film but as a richly
thrilling crime saga
i think you and i
are destined to do this forever
you'll be in a better channel forever
maybe we could share one
you know they'll be doubling up the rate
this city's inhabitants are losing their
minds this city
just showed you
that it's full of people
ready to believe in good until their
spirit breaks completely
until they get a good look at the real
harvey dent
huh
and all the heroic things he's done
you didn't think i'd
risk losing the battle for gotham's soul
in a fist fight with you
you need
an ace in the hole
mine's harvey
what did you do i took gotham's white
knight
and i
brought him down our level
it wasn't hard see madness as you know
is
like gravity
all it takes is a little push
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of that
entertainment content you love and until
next time i am your host naz perez and
we'll see you back here for more top 10s
on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you